[Music]
they're villains
Heroes don't kill people
well I do hello everyone my name is Naz
Perez and I am sitting here with the
cast of The highly anticipated Black
Adam and can I just say I feel like you
can cut the Charisma in this room with a
knife I mean like what again look at
that
yes this is a huge deal guys for
everybody watching and everyone's
sitting here right now because I don't
know if a lot of people know this but
when it comes to like big superhero
team-ups before there ever was that
Justice League or The Avengers are
Fantastic Four there was the Justice
Society of America they were the very
first superhero team in comic book
history how cool is that right to you
guys you get to see them on the big
screen in live action which I think is
just so huge so just wanted to take a
second to sort of let that marinate but
Dwayne I know you thank you by the way
Naz for saying that because a lot of
times like a lot of people don't know
that that JSA predated uh you know
Justice League and you name it so yeah
thank you for pointing that out of
course you guys look great too yeah
Dwayne you've been working on this movie
for like 10 years and you've been in
over 40 films and you've played
everything from Scorpion King to a tooth
fairy and I know growing up as a kid I'm
sorry now it's one second I'm sorry what
I'm sorry what what the [ __ ] why what
was the giggle did you hear this that
was like like a judgey like judging no
just the prettiest
it was supportive I heard it was
supportive did you hear support him it
was like it was like haha that was
awesome yeah I didn't get that yeah I
felt good we're gonna see Dwayne Johnson
I immediately think of that role
okay all right I'm so sorry so Scorpion
King Tooth Fairy
really all your characters because
there's been so many different
incarnations of your characters and
various Source material before we dive
deep I just wanted to go around real
quick maybe tell us one or two sentences
on how your character relates Black Adam
in this movie and we'll start with you
quintessence
Black Adam in this movie yeah well I
feel like it's throughout the film
there's just this over like arching
question of you know what it takes to
liberate a people and provide like
freedom and I think
Cyclone questions that and relates to
Black Adam in that way Pierce that is Dr
Faith relate to blackout in this movie
um Dr Fate relates with caution he's a
man who can foresee the future he's a
man who is bestowed with this power of
the helmet of Naboo
which is kind of a blessing and a curse
to him it's an addiction in some
respects and he's a man that uh
you know has a deep friendship with
Hawkman
who I respect I'm the Elder of the the
quartet and he has his own Secrets at
the beginning of the film which is his
own personal Journey as well
so that really intrigued me
and that this is the first time you
really see the character of Kent Nelson
portrayed
um on film
as uh as Dr Fate by the way I do want to
point out that first time you see all of
these characters for the first time on
film together especially since they've
been around for decades and decades so
it's really cool no it's huge huge deal
and Dr Fate's such a fan favorite people
are so excited to see you in that role
tell us how Adam Smasher really
he has an open mind and uh he's very
excited to be a part of the Justice
Society and then he meets Black Adam and
Black Adam has an entirely new take on
what is good and what his rights one
that differs quite strongly from the
Justice Society and I think that
is something that Adam Smasher really
admires the Black Adam so he sees in
this man or in this God not just a
villain but maybe a different take on
Justice
maybe a more accurate one
yeah
Hawkman and Black Adam friends what's
going on
um it's it's almost there's almost a
similar nature to to what you said I
mean you know Hawkman is leader of the
JSA through his time he has had to
Define and redefine what Justice is to
him and that's what he leads with but
when he engages Black Adam Black Adam
challenges what that definition is it
challenges his theories his thoughts
because of the fact that even though he
does what he does he believes in what he
does and he moves to the beat of his own
drum
Black Adam
walks through his own Rhythm as well and
I think there's sort of a
even though they're adversaries I
believe there's a sense of respect
because there's a sense of recognition
in one of
them
I love that you said challenge because I
feel like when you get a bunch of
superheroes in a room together it's
highly unlikely they're all going to get
along or be on the same page do we get
to see you guys fight each other oh they
all sing Kumbaya
um
you know yeah we go at it well and your
goal not only did you know Black Adam
and Hawkman go at it we also wanted to
make sure that we were as best we could
uh pangomaj to mythology and the comic
mythology so yeah we have to go at it
but also you know it's the
um intention of the entire JSA to stop
Black Adam and put them away I love that
you brought up the mythology Dwayne
because my favorite line Black Adam says
in the JSA Black Rain comic is the
present can never be agreed upon and I
love that line so much because he's such
an anti-hero and because I personally
feel like Dwayne you are just like as
wholesome as apple pie
tooth fairies baby I wanted to ask you
because Black Adam you know straddles
that line of good and bad in a similar
way that you did in your wrestling days
turning from a face to a heel a few
times did you feel close to that
wrestling character at all or tap into
it to sort of get that balance of good
and bad for blackout oh that's
interesting yes it wasn't my lead foot
when thinking about the character and
standing him up on its feet and
breathing life into him uh but no doubt
my experience as a pro wrestler where I
would uh continuously straddle the line
of good and bad and eventually it got to
a place in that world of pro wrestling
where uh it was just an accepted thing
that when the character of The Rock
comes out uh he'll do things that might
be questionable but at the end of the
day everyone in the arena under of why
and that's how they left so same thing
very similar to Black Adam you may not
agree with his philosophy but at the end
you do understand why wow so there may
be a people's eyebrows it might be
slightly major wrestling fan thank you
James Bond fan I mean Pierce you have
gotten to drive the fanciest cars in
James Bond you have sang in Mamma Mia
and in this movie you have a golden
helmet and super power so I wanted to
know is this the nerdiest thing you've
ever done and what was really fun about
this
no this was not the nerdiest uh I've
done nerdier I think uh this was a
powerful experience to share with with
this you know my fellow actors here and
uh Gemma Colette Sarah you know did such
a magnificent job magnificent job and
there was such a good sense of
camaraderie on the set between us all
and you know these films are Monumental
the sets of the biggest sets that I've
ever seen I saw some big ones on the
James Bond movies it was a delight every
day wow did you guys like ask him all
the James Bond questions
appears as a 90s kid I feel like I
personally have to thank you for a
golden eye on Nintendo 64. thank you
thank you same well I love that you said
same artist because I know you've been a
major Comic Book fan since forever and
when Dwayne and called you to offer you
the role you didn't even like believe it
was him no when you saw the trailer
there's this epic moment where we see
Hawkman
what was it like for you to see yourself
suited up for the first
time oh it was amazing I mean for me I
was waiting on the wings you know I've
been wearing that suit for months and I
was like oh
baby we better be ready because uh you
know you can only imagine sort of the
grandiose nature of what it is you're
you're sitting there first of all the
day that we all got to set we all saw
each other in our suits we were like oh
it's real it's like cool you know what I
mean it's happening but then when you
see it all put together you see the
trailer that's when your imagination
completely explodes and you know when
you're working on it that this is
something truly incredible but this is
something that you work on it and then
you watch it you really get to be a fan
you get to be a kid again because your
mind is really just going all crazy with
what you've actually accomplished the
the magnitude of what you accomplish is
so huge and it is really truly one of
those dream come true type of deals so
for me
first time I saw it full out I was just
I was kind of floored speechless taken
back because now you're a part of
something that is truly in its Essence
and it's full Essence uh
something that has the power and will
and can change the the the notion of
perception perspective ideas belief
representation this is what the value of
the work is that we do art in this
purest form we get to influence and
Inspire and that's something that you
know this inspires true imagination it
choosing these inspires belief and
inspires ambition to go push for those
dreams so when you see that costume for
me it's more than just putting on a suit
yeah it's putting on dreams you know
what I mean that was so beautifully said
I gotta tell you really quick that just
from my perspective as when I when I
came on set and I saw all these guys
walk on for the first time as Aldous was
saying not only did it become real dream
come true but I everyone all of my
fellow actors here are also incredibly
talented all of them I think
um really embraced this idea that we
could do something that's pretty cool
with Black Adam and JSA for the first
time introducing essay to the world so
they all came to set with this just this
what and you could feel it pulsing like
Mana I was talking about mana and they
all came to set from quintesso when when
they came on uh looking how they looked
I was like oh my God that blew my mind
and of course Noah came on look at how
he looked in his the Hawkman came on
wings and all and then finally it was
almost like out of the smoke
doctor face with the gold helmet out of
the gold helmet I was like oh my all of
us were like holy [ __ ] I thought you
were gonna say that the mo cap suit
that's where she was going with nerdy
and I love how you said wearing dreams
that was so beautifully said and the
Mana because quintesso when you spoke at
Comic-Con and you said that playing
Cyclone was the biggest honor of your
life I thought that that was so touching
and because she's this character that's
really trying to figure out who she is I
was wondering how did she help you sort
of come close to who you are as an actor
100 okay so with with Cyclone there's
like this element of play that she like
Embraces and just like even
a really big part of that play was also
in the way that she moves and how she
emits her power itself and so when I was
figuring out what that was and what that
movement looked like it also allowed me
to find a comfort in my body that I
think as a trans person is very rough of
a journey and so as I like danced and I
moved I was like wow I can open up
myself
in ways that I haven't before and like
really Embrace like who this character
is and have fun on set and play with
things and really just like open up in
ways that I think for me as a person is
very hard and also as like an actor I
think
I've you know been on this journey of
growing into and so having that and also
having Jama and like you know everyone
honestly be so open to the creativity of
like Cyclone herself and the way she
dresses and it being a little bit like
circusy and just you know very different
um being able to represent that also as
a person of color where I feel like we
really haven't seen someone unique like
that like and just the way that she
looks and how she has fun with herself
like
you know just dressing and the makeup
and you know like her costume it was
just very like amazing of like an
opportunity you know you know so yeah
and it's so cool to see you in that role
because Cyclone is such a rich comic
book history you know she's an update to
Red Tornado one of the first female
superheroes ever it's wild Noah when I
watched a trailer the first thing I
wanted to ask you was what is it like
being bigger than the rock yeah dude
Kevin Hart has to borrow your power
that's so good yeah well first and
foremost I started calling Dwayne the
pebble
wow
oh my God oh my God
Jerry's out on Kevin Hart I think he's I
think you've intimidated him on the last
question for Super Pets I think he's
still he's recovering yeah but he's also
killing it on his tour from what I
understand you don't have to give up man
shout out what are you doing please
please he's also killing it on his tour
please
Jesus just keep it here
also if you haven't bought tickets yet
they're on free ships they are how this
is going on foreign
I know a lot of people are going to walk
into this movie Dwayne wondering are we
going to see any Justice League
characters in this movie because we know
the JSA is a precursor to the Justice
League so that connection Fell in This
film what can you tell us I can tell you
that we're just gonna have to wait and
see I gotta ask you one last question
um and it's about firsts I really
struggle with first and doing things for
the first time and this is your first
time ever playing a superhero do you get
nervous at all when you do stuff like
this for the first time and if so like
how do you push through that
uh that's a great question um
I wasn't nervous to play Black Adam I
was just really so
um
just keenly aware and present in the
opportunity that I had with uh these
guys who I consider family the
opportunity that we all had to deliver
not only all of our characters for the
first time globally
um
but also
just the opportunity I've been very
lucky over the course of my career so to
be able to do a first like this I
recognize the responsibility of it
recognize the excitement of it so I
wasn't that nervous as because I'd went
into this like all of us did just
preparing our butts off for it and
really making sure that by the time we
stepped on set we were ready to go as
best we could so I wanted to eliminate
you know when you're unsure and unclear
of things and you didn't prepare
properly that's when you could get a
little nervous so I knew what this
opportunity was I was going to do my
best not to screw it up and also there's
a responsibility that I had to them and
to our crew our our studio and
uh more so just as important the fans
yeah so I was ready to go well that is a
great place to end on my friends we are
so close to smelling with The Rock and
his cast has been cooking for the last
10 years tickets are on sale right now
for Black Adam get your tickets on
fandango.com thank you guys so much
great job thank you so much for watching
thank you for saying yeah thank you guys
thank you thank you remember Kevin
harties